sumemos 4 11 a vos más 9 sobre 13 para
poder sumar estas dos fracciones
necesitamos encontrar el común
denominador y ese común denominador es
el mínimo común múltiplo de 11 y 13 como
estos dos números no tienen factores en
común el mínimo común múltiplo va a ser
simplemente el producto de 11 y 13 así
que lo calculamos 13 por 13 por 11 1 por
36 13 1 por 13 es 13 también no podemos
decir que 13 por 10 630 sumamos y esto
nos va a dar 3 41 143 y ese va a ser
nuestro común denominador
así es que luego escribir aquí aquí
tenemos algo sobre 143 más algo más
sobre 143 y para ir desde 4 hacia vos
hasta algo sobre 143 multiplicamos 11
por 13 y multiplicamos el denominador
por 13 así es que tenemos que
multiplicar el numerador también por 13
y 4 por 13 es 4 por 10 es 40
a 4 por 312 lo que nos da en total 52
puedes hacer los cálculos a mano 4 por 3
igual a 52 y luego para ir de 13 a 143
multiplicamos el denominador por 11 si
no queremos que se altere el valor de la
fracción multiplicamos el numerador
también por 11 9 por 11 es igual a 99 y
estamos listos para hacer la suma esto
es igual a nuestro denominador es 143 y
el número 52 más 99 sumamos 52 más tiene
152 y esto va a ser uno menos que eso
por lo cual va a ser 151 y me parece que
la fracción ya está simplificada que yo
sepa no hay factores en común entre 151
y 143 obtenemos 151 sobre 143 lo podemos
escribir como un número mixto tenemos
que 143 cabe una vez en 151 uno por 143
643 hacemos la red está aquí tenemos 11
esto pasa a ser 4 11 menos 3 es 8
tenemos un residuo de 8
así que 151 sobre 143 es lo mismo que un
entero y 8 143 abós y ahora es más
evidente que esto no puede simplificarse
más y hemos terminado y esto es lo mismo
que un entero haré el uno más grande y 8
143 ambos